- Mr. Carling, I have the conn.
- Captain has the conn.
- Right standard rudder at 0-7-9.
- Right standard rudder to 0-7-9.
Aye-aye, sir.
- All escorts, Greyhound.
Return to your stations immediately.
We have enemy contact, bearing 0-8-7.
- Just imagine any way a sheep
would try to escape a pack of wolves,
and you've got a ship trying to
get away from the Nazi submarines.
That was the game of
The Battle of the Atlantic.
- A wolf pack shadowing us.
- They'll attack as a group.
- Yeah, waiting for nightfall.
- "Greyhound" is about
an American destroyer
escorting a convoy of merchant vessels
that's crossing the Atlantic
to bring vital war material
and soldiers to our allies.
- Captain Krause has been
given quite a lot of responsibility
as a first time commander.
It's a bit of a trial by fire.
- Hard right rudder!
Hard over!
- The Nazis had submarines, U-boats,
and their job was to sink any allied ship
that was floating at sea.
(sonar pinging)
- That dead silence...
...and just waiting to see
what's on your radar screen.
(sonar pinging)
You can imagine how it must've felt for
the men back then, coming under attack.
- He's trying to slip under us!
- All mounts, fire at will.
- We're nowhere near air cover,
we're low on fuel.
No one has any idea
if they are going to make it.
- U-boat, starboard bow!
- What you did yesterday...
got us to today.
- It's not enough, Charlie.
Not nearly enough.
- Krause has a lot of pressure on himself
'cause he has a lot of lives at his hands,
and every decision he makes determines
the outcome of the whole crew.
- I don't think there's any commander
that doesn't have
this innate fear of being wrong.
But that has to be conquered.
You cannot let your command
be governed by this nagging doubt
of, "What if I am wrong?"
- Here they come.
- The goods will be
delivered by this nation,
whose Navy believes
in the tradition of,
"Damn the torpedoes,
full speed ahead."
- All hands, brace for collision!